je viens des champions maintenant donc
parce que moi m'avait dit que toutes les
chaînes avaient été nettoyés la soirée
commence à peine à l'hôtel crowne
centre-ville de montréal et déjà le
personnel en a plein les bras
les 150 places mises à la disposition de
personnes en situation d'itinérance
attaques de la colline sont déjà
promises et malgré l'existence d'un
deuxième hôtel qui offrent 50 places ça
ne change pas le fait qu'on refuse d
autant les 460 distance n'ont pas de
place où aller s'ils sont en santé que
c'est très triste d'avoir accès à une
place d'isolement y a plus place nulle
part on est devant un dilemme est ce que
le froid ou les risques d'attraper la
coved c'est quoi le lait c'est quoi la
priorité le troisième il est plein le
quatrième est plein on les range
maintenant c'est cet âge à chaque fois
dès l'ouverture la soirée même s'était
rempli complet
pendant l'isolément des usagers les
intervenants s'assure que tout le monde
prend ses médicaments et propose aussi
une forme de sevrage à ceux qui ont des
problèmes de consommation pour rendre
leur séjour possible il n'y a toutefois
pas de personnel médical sur place si
vous
si vous n'avez pas eu 100 ans il vous
avez fait deux vaccins depuis que tu es
après 100 jours
brian et michel partage une chambre
depuis vendredi et déjà ils
réfléchissent à où ils 0 après leur
période d élevage et khalid al [ __ ]
allons pour la gueule mavuba pam ou 30 à
vie
puis je le place où aller mam a bien
voulu me chercher un peu son jeu entre
jean bras un bébé vous tombez pas dans
le
panneau et
portent
gravés l'avait pas prévu que la balle a
eu trois semaines
en milieu de soirée une bonne nouvelle
tombe pour ceux qui peinent à trouver un
toit normalement quand on en est close
on peut pas faire d admission un rein
par exemple dans mon service régulier
d'hébergement d'urgence mais là vu la
situation vu les grands froids on aime
consigne officielle de prioriser les
admissions et d'oublier un peu la cage
vide
mais au delà de la création de places
dans les refuges c'est le personnel
qualifié qui manquent pour répondre aux
besoins des personnes dans la rue je
suis aujourd'hui des courriels de
médecins retraités les jours comme ça
avec qui on a travaillé dans le parti
sis part apprécié mais on a besoin de
quelqu'un de savoir que quelqu'un va
être de 8 à 4 khatami ni d'avoir
coordination
pour cette raison que les personnes en
situation d'itinérance atteintes de
lakovic vont être déplacés bientôt au
stade de soccer de montréal l'endroit a
va permettre d'offrir 320 places et
surtout de regrouper toutes les
ressources sous un même toit même a320
que ça sera pas nécessairement suffisant
le pour accueillir la la l'augmentation
déconne pour les personnes en situation
d'itinérance
burbaud pour le stade de soccer devrait
accueillir ses premiers usagers dès
cette semaine les deux hôtels déjà
mobilisés vont devenir des ondes vertes
pour accueillir les personnes qui ne
trouvent pas de place en refuge